>> Tucker: IT’S DEMOCRATS HAVE
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THEY PLAN TO
PUT JOE BIDEN THE WHITE HOUSE IN
JANUARY WHETHER HE WINS THE
ELECTION OR NOT.
WATCH.
>> JOE BIDEN SHOULD NOT CONCEDE
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO DRAG
OUT AND EVENTUALLY I DO BELIEVE
HE WILL WIN IF WE DON’T GIVE AN
INCH AND IF WE ARE AS FOCUSED
AND RELENTLESS AS THE OTHER SIDE
IS.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER ANGRY RICH
LADY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THOSE AROUND.
TODAY, JEFF BEZOS’ PERSONAL
NEWSPAPER "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTED THAT VIOLENCE IS LIKELY
IF JOE BIDEN DOESN’T WIN BUT OF
COURSE NOT PREDICTED IF HE DOES
WHEN WHICH TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
ACCORDING TO "THE BOSTON GLOBE,"
BIDEN SURROGATE JOHN PODESTA HAS
BEEN PLANNING FOR THE
POSSIBILITY THAT BIDEN WON’T
CONCEDE AND THAT THE MILITARY
WILL GET INVOLVED AND MAKE SURE
HE IS PRESIDENT.
IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE ANYONE
WOULD SAY THAT OUT LOUD BUT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT OUT LOUD.
WHAT ARE THE SCENARIOS ON WHAT’S
LIKELY TO HAPPEN.
THIS ONE IS NOT HARD TO PREDICT
THAT ALL.
THIS ONE IS SETTING UP TO BE A
DUMPSTER FIRE.
AND, I’M THINKING, THAT NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
EXPERTS UPWARDS OF 156 MILLION
AMERICANS WILL CAST A BALLOT IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
AND THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
THAT’S ANYONE WHO HAS SEEN WHO
IS ALIVE TODAY.
DOES A MAIL SYSTEM WORK?
THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTION
MARKS WITH THAT BUT WE HAD SO
MANY FELT PRIMARIES ALREADY AND,
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN NEVADA,
THAT IS NOT ACCOUNTED FOR, THEY
WERE REJECTED IN NEW YORK.
HOW DO YOU CONSIDER A SINGLE
BATTLEGROUND STATE BECAUSE OF A
LAPSE LIKE THAT, THAT WILL BE A
DISASTER.
>> AND THAT’S A QUESTION BETWEEN
THE PARTIES DO YOU GET THE
FEELING THAT IT IS YOUR PROGRAM?
>> YES, THEY HAVE AN ARMY OF
LAWYERS AND UNQUESTIONABLE
DESIRE TO WIN.
AND THERE IS UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT JOE BIDEN
CONCEDES THAT ELECTION.
HE CONCEDES PLAYING JOE BIDEN
THEY WOULD COMMIT THE
ELECTORATES TO THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE AND IN THEIR WORKING
SCENARIOS OF THREE STATES
WASHINGTON, OREGON AND
CALIFORNIA ALL THREE OF THE
STATES ON THE WESTERN SEABOARD
THREATENED TO SECEDE FROM.
IT’S A GIGANTIC DEAL.
THERE IS REALLY ONLY ONE
SOLUTION TO ALL OF THIS.
YOU HAVE TO GET THE POLLS OPEN.
YOU HAVE VERY LITTLE TIME AND IS
OF IMMENSE IMPORTANCE THAT
PEOPLE VOTE IMPORTANCE.
IF YOU CANNOT HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THE ELECTION SYSTEM, THE WHOLE
THING FALLS APART.
THREATENED FUNDING AND FORCE
STATES TO REOPEN BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW, THE STATES GOVERNORS ARE
SHUTTING DOWN POLLS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WE NEED A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN
THIS ELECTION RESULT AND WE NEED
IT QUICKLY.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT’S A
VERY SMART POINTS, AND IT’S
SOMETHING THAT REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS, NOT ONE OF THE